hey what's up guys my name is a cello
and welcome to an update video and I
have not done an update video and really
really long so here we go I'm gonna
update you guys with what's going on and
and what's going on with this channel
and all that stuff okay great so first
of all it's Easter right this is my
Easter Connor this is the next this
weekend coming up is East 28th to 2014
weekend which is fantastic now for a few
reasons a I get like over a week off
from uni which is really really cool and
that's gonna kind of you'll see that
carry across in a minute
but also because you know to celebrate
Easter what I'm doing is I'm actually
having a bit of a sale on my website for
the tutoring okay so if you guys don't
know I do offer private tutoring and
basically this is meant for people who
who want to either learn Java they want
to learn C++ they want to learn OpenGL
they want to learn how to make games
privately you know just for me teaching
them directly face-to-face you know the
way that I do it by the way is over
Skype right so we set up a voice call
over Skype and then there's TeamViewer
running so that you guys can see my
screen in the best way possible and and
essentially it's just it's just me
pretty much talking for an hour or half
an hour depending on what you choose you
know the hour is from the much more
popular choice here because um half now
you can't really get much done in that
time but the idea is yeah and so I am I
teach you you know programming languages
or how to make games 2d games 3d games
OpenGL all that all that fun stuff so I
won't talk a bit about that because last
time I talked about this was when I put
up the video when I first started this
and you know since then it's been about
um almost a month I think and and it's
been really successful right everyone
who's had a session and I'm not making
this up I promise
eighty-three percent of the clients that
basically had a first session are still
actually continuing with with it right
so they've had like four or five and
they they're still going they're
enjoying it like crazy and out of
everyone who had one session with me 93%
of them ordered another one like within
24 hours that's how that's how much
these guys are loving it and the idea is
you know I mean I consider myself pretty
good at teaching things right that's why
I'm doing this YouTube thing because hey
I enjoy it and B I feel like I can
actually bring something to the
community of game programming and game
development as well as just normal
programming but it's going really really
well so I highly recommend that you guys
look into it especially now here's your
chance right because just for this
weekend pretty much up until Easter
Monday up until the end of May based on
Monday so including Easter Monday the
entire whatever you choose
in terms of tutoring options it will be
20% off all right so instead of eating
$50 per hour it's $40 per hour right and
what I've actually done due to popular
little quest because again all these
people are ordering so many tutorials
here that if you order it in bulk you
actually get a pretty good discount
right so basically let's just say if you
order six tutorials right that would be
$300 this is uh not counting the sale by
the way it would be $300 but what
happens is you can actually order
basically five straightaway which is
$250 and you actually get a sixth one
for free so you get a free six tutorial
if you want a five basically and of
course if you order them all upfront and
because of this sale though that's being
reduced by 20% down to $200 so it's $200
for $300 worth of tutorials basically
which is a really good deal but you know
for those of you who are starting out
and you don't really sure if you'd like
me or if you think I can you know I can
teach you something then there is the
half hour option in which you can try it
out that's down to $24 from 30 so that's
a cool way to check it out as well but
honestly I would recommend you guys give
it a shot
if you guys are really hugely advanced
and you guys are like computer mages
you've finished degrees and you're like
40 years old and you've got your own
company you don't expect me to be able
to teach you something that you might
not already know okay if you maybe if
you diving into game developer you
haven't before I can teach you that
stuff but you know I'm not I'm not
Superman I can't teach you everything
there is to know I haven't learned
everything there is to know obviously
and I'm accepting their no I'm telling
you that upfront right I'm not here to
scare me or anything but I do know like
a good deal and and if you guys are just
starting out or you're just you're in
you're in the place where you don't
really even understanding Java that well
or you want to accelerate your learning
then I feel that this is a just the best
way to do it because the status
action is absent literally everyone's
been like this is amazing thank you so
much so that's that okay I know I talked
a lot about that but you can see I'm
really passionate about that and it's
just it's working wonderfully so I'm
really happy about that
secondly because of this hub because of
this week that I have off there's also
an Zack tech coming up so I that's why I
have the entire week off and that's next
week that is as well as today which is
Thursday and Friday I'm actually gonna
start a new series okay this is weird
because I haven't finished game
programming in 3d game programming I
haven't brought that back yet but what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make a series
but what I'm gonna do is gonna be a mini
series right so maybe a massive series
gonna be maybe 20 episodes probably less
I said that about now watch at
programming I was like yeah 10 episodes
but it yeah it took like or was it like
33 I think so I'm not gonna say I'm in
the episodes it's gonna be but some I'm
gonna finish the whole thing before I
upload the first episode that is that's
what I'm gonna do okay beside that
because I don't have time to to complete
it later on I don't want to leave you
guys hanging like I did with them with
another certain series I call 3d and
programming but basically um it's gonna
be how to make flappy bird from scratch
okay game programming it's gonna be a
while until we finish that I've accepted
that that's like gonna be the series
that lasts throughout the entire life of
my channel right I probably not gonna
end until I you know quit YouTube or
something if I ever will so game
programming is one of those extended
series right this is gonna be like a
quick series okay there's not much to
make in flappy bird and the reason I got
this series idea by the way is because I
was really bored Anna lecturer at
University and it about to two maybe
three hours I made flappy bird from
scratch and and I thought you know what
this is this is this took me like
nothing and it actually covers like you
know everything from from basic graphics
rendering to you know some collision to
like game over screens high-score menus
all that stuff he covers like a lot of
the aspects of games and it only took me
like two hours max so I tweeted out and
I was like would you guys be interested
in a series like this so do you think I
should do that and everyone said yes so
I thought you know what let's actually
do this so I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
record the whole thing and then I'm
gonna put it up daily so you guys will
get one Episode per day until it runs
out but the whole thing's gonna be
finished before I even put out the first
episode because that's something I
really want to do okay and then what I
want to do that in is Java not in them
not in open sorry not in pixel array
kind of thing I'm just gonna use a
graphics class and make it harder I
didn't through that but what am I do
with that series is successful I have
this major idea in me that I want to do
like three versions of every series
right so I want to do this flappy bird
series first of all in Java using the
inbuilt libraries then I want to do it
in like say plus plus using maybe like a
pixel array or something and then I want
to do it in OpenGL as well all right
that's kind of my because I like being
able to do it three ways and show you
guys the difference and not do it from
scratch maybe but just unplug the
renderer plug in a different render and
set and show you guys how that works so
I don't know how that's gonna work out
logistically but that's that's kind of
the gist right that's the flappy bird
series okay that's gonna happen now it's
gonna be on desktop it's not gonna be a
mobile app that's one thing I probably
should have mentioned straight away
we're not gonna be making a mobile app
we could but I don't really enjoy doing
that
honestly just to be frank with you
there's a lot of setting up to do and
it's not a lot of them just garbage so
it's gonna be for desktop we'll probably
make it work inside a web browser as
well but something like that so you guys
would be interested in that be sure to
leave a like on this video leave a
comment letting me know um what else
what else what else is that it update
video right it's been ages yes Archer no
answer no engines coming out coming up
coming
I guess it's um what's the right English
word here it's coming along nicely
right there's a lot of you guys
contribute you're contributing on the
git repository haven't really been
looking at issues yet because I've been
busy a bit this week but now that I'm
done I'm probably gonna stream tomorrow
so maybe in about like nine ten hours
after this video goes out I'll
definitely put up a video on my youtube
channel where I will be streaming but
I'm going to continue streaming that lot
um dare is oh this is another thing I
should mention there is next weekend so
it's not this Easter weekend it's the
next one and I'm gonna be doing a lot of
course using the channel engine that's
the whole idea right but so obviously
said I'm gonna stream that entire thing
that entire weekend I don't know how I'm
gonna manage streaming with my little
Internet
here with my 1.2 megabytes per second op
but some gonna we're gonna hope that's
gonna be good anyway
that's it okay tryna mention streams
have been awesome hundreds of people
have been showing out for them and we've
been having a really good time I've been
playing a lot amuse during that and it's
just been it's been an awesome time okay
anyway that's it guys so I hope you
enjoyed this update video make sure oh
this is another thing I want to mention
about the tutoring you don't have to
book it tutorial for this Eastern fan um
I'm not gonna you know do any tutorials
on Easter but um it's anything that you
book like during this sale period so you
could book her tutorial for like a year
from now but as long as you book it in
you pay for it during this period which
is up until the 21st which is Monday you
get that discounted price so you could
literally book only years worth of
tutorials for that discount price and of
course that would be fine so that's the
idea you don't have to if you're not
free this week um I'm not gonna be free
this weekend either so you can see my
availability there on the channel to
come for tutoring and of course the link
is in the description and stuff like
that anyway hope you guys enjoyed this
video don't forget hit like button I'll
see you guys very very frequently during
this Easter break goodbye